MICHALE FEE: OK.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
So what is neural computation?
So neuroscience used to be
a very descriptive field
where you would describe the
different kinds of neurons.
Who here has seen the famous
pictures-- the old pictures
of the golgi-stained neurons,
all those different types
of neurons, describing what
things look like in the brain
and what parts of the brain
are important for what
kinds of behavior based
on lesion studies.
It used to be
extremely descriptive.
But things are changing
in neuroscience,
and have changed dramatically
over the past few decades.
Really, neuroscience now is
about understanding the brain,
how the brain works, how
the brain produces behavior.
And really trying to develop
engineering-level descriptions
of brain systems and brain
circuits and neurons and ion
channels and all the components
of neurons that make the brain
work.
And so, for example,
the level of description
that my lab works at and
that I'm most excited about
is understanding how neural
circuits-- how neurons
are put together to make
neural circuits that
implement behaviors,
or to produce
let's say object recognition.
So this is a figure
from Jim DiCarlo,
who is our department head.
Basically a
circuit-level description
of how the brain goes
from a visual stimulus
to a recognition of what that
object is in the stimulus.
Now at the same
time that there's
been a big push toward
understanding or generating
an engineering level
descriptions of brains
and circuits and
components, neurons,
there's also been tremendous
advances in the technologies
that we can use
to record neurons.
So there are now imaging
systems and microscopes
that can image thousands
of neurons simultaneously.
This is an example of a movie
recorded in an awake baby mouse
that's basically dreaming.
And let me just show you
what this looks like.
So this is a mouse that has
a fluorescent protein that's
sensitive to neural activity.
And so when neurons in a part
of the brain become active
they become fluorescent
and light up.
And so here's a top surface
of the mouse's brain.
And you can see this spontaneous
activity flickering around
as this mouse is just
dreaming and thinking
about whatever it's
thinking about.
So one of the key
challenges is to take images
like this that represent
the activity of thousands
of neurons or
millions of neurons
and figure out how to relate
that to the circuit models that
are being developed.
So here's another example.
So there are these new probes
where these are basically
silicon probes
that have thousands
of little sensors on
them and a computer here
that basically reads out
the pattern of activity.
These are called neuropixels.
So those are
basically electrodes
that can, again, record
from thousands of neurons
simultaneously.
And they're quite
long and can record
throughout the whole brain,
essentially, all at once.
So the key now is you have these
very high dimensional data set.
How do you relate that
to the circuit models
that you're developing?
And so one of the key
challenges in neuroscience
is to take very
large data sets that
look like this that
just look like a mess
and figure out what's going
on underneath of there.
It turns out that people are
discovering that while you
might be recording from
tens of thousands of neurons
and it looks really
messy that there's
some underlying very simple
structure underneath of there.
But you can't see
it when you just
look at big collections
of neurons like this.
So the challenge here
is really to figure out
how to not only just
make those models,
but test them by taking
data and relating
the patterns of activity
that you see in these very
high dimensional data sets,
do dimensionality reduction--
compress that data down into
a simple representation--
and then relate it to those
models that you developed.
One of the things we're going
to try to do in this class
is to apply these techniques
of making models of neurons
and circuits together
with mathematical tools
for analyzing data in
the context of looking
at animal behaviors.
So for example, in my lab
we study how songbirds sing,
how they learn to produce
their vocalizations.
Songbirds learn by
imitating their parents.
They listen to their parents.
[BIRDS SINGING]
Here, hold on.
I'm going to skip ahead.
How do I do that?
[BIRDS SINGING]
[INAUDIBLE] bring up the--
I was hoping I'd be
able to skip ahead.
So this is just a
setup showing how
we can record from neurons in
birds while they're singing
and figure out how
those circuits work
to produce the song.
This is a little
micro-drive that we built.
It's motorized so that we
can move these electrodes
around independently in the
brain and record from neurons
without the animal knowing that
we're moving the electrodes
around and looking for neurons.
So songbirds are really cool.
They listen to their parents.
They store a memory of
what their parents sing.
And then they begin babbling.
And they practice over and
over again until they can learn
a good copy of their song.
So here's a bird that's
singing with the micro-drive
on its head.
And you can hear the
neuron in the background.
[STATIC SOUNDS]
Sorry, it's not over
the loudspeaker here.
But can everyone hear that?
So we can record from neurons
while the bird is singing.
[BIRDS SINGING]
Look at the activity
in this network
and try to figure out
how that network actually
works to produce the song.
And also we can record
in very young birds
and figure out how the
song is actually learned.
And there's an example
of a neuron generating
action potentials, which is
the basic unit of communication
in the brain.
[BIRDS SINGING]
And we try to build
circuit models
and figure out how that
thing actually works
to produce and learn this song.
So these computational
approaches
that I'm talking
about are not just
important for dissecting brain
circuits related to behavior.
The same kinds of
approaches, the same kind
of dimensionality reduction
techniques we're going to learn
are also useful in
molecular genetic studies,
like taking
transcriptional profiling
and doing clustering and looking
at the different patterns that
are there.
It's also useful for
molecular studies.
Also, these ideas are very
powerful in studying cognition.
So if you look at the work
that Josh Tenenbaum does
and Josh McDermott, who
developed mathematical models
of how our minds work, how we
learn to think about things,
those are also very model-based
and very quantitative.
So the kinds of tools we're
going to learn in this class
are very broadly applicable.
They're also increasingly
important in medicine.
So at some point we're going to
take a little bit of a detour
to look at a particular
disease that's caused
by a defect in an ion channel.
And it turns out
you can understand
exactly how that defect
in that ion channel
relates to the phenotype
of the disease.
And you can do that by creating
a mathematical model of how
a neuron behaves when it
has an ion channel that
has this defect in it.
So it's very cool.
And once you model
it, you can really
understand why that happens.
So here are some of
the course goals.
So we're going to
start by working
on basic biophysics of
neurons and networks
and other principles underlying
brain and cognitive functions.
We're going to develop
mathematical techniques
to analyze those models and
to analyze the behavioral data
and neural data
that you would take
to study those brain circuits.
And along the way, we're going
to become proficient at using
MATLAB to do these things.
So how many of you have
experience with MATLAB?
OK, great.
And not?
So anybody who doesn't have
experience with MATLAB,
we're going to really make
an effort to bring you up
to speed very quickly.
Daniel has actually just
created a very nice MATLAB cheat
sheet that's just amazing.
So there will be lots of
help with programming.
So let me just mention
some of the topics
that we'll be covering.
So we'll be talking
about equivalent circuit
model of neurons.
So let me just explain
how this is broken down.
So these are topics
that we'll be covering.
And these are the
mathematical tools
that go along with
those topics that we'll
be learning about in parallel.
So we'll be studying
neuronal biophysics.
And we'll be doing some
differential equations
along the way for that, just
first-order linear differential
equations, nothing
to be scared of.
We'll talk about
neuronal responses
to stimuli and tuning curves.
And along the way,
we'll be learning
about spike sorting and
peristimulus, time histograms,
and ways of analyzing
firing patterns.
We talked about neural
coding and receptive fields.
And we'll learn about
correlation and convolution
for that topic.
We'll talk about feed forward
networks and perceptrons.
And then we're going
to start bringing
a lot of linear algebra,
which is really fun.
It's really powerful.
And that linear
algebra sets the stage
for then doing
dimensionality, reduction
on data, and principal component
analysis, and singular value
decomposition, and other things.
We'll then take an additional
extension of neural networks
from feed forward networks.
We'll figure out how
to make them talk back
to themselves so they
can start doing things
like remember things
and make decisions.
And that involves more
linear algebra, eigenvalues.
And then I'm not
sure we're going
to get time to sensory
integration and Bayes' rule.
So by the end of
the class, there
are some important
skills that you'll have.
You'll be able to think
about a neuron very clearly
and how its components
work together
to give that neuron
its properties.
And how neurons themselves
can connect together
to give a neural
circuit its properties.
You'll be able to write
MATLAB programs that
simulate those models.
You'll be able to analyze
data using MATLAB.
You'll be able to visualize
high dimensional data sets.
And one of my
goals in this class
is that you guys
should be able to go
into any lab in the
department and do
cool things that even the
graduate students may not
know how to do.
And so you can do really
great stuff as a UROP.
So one of the most important
things about this class
is problem sets
because that's where
you're going to get the hands-on
experience to do that data
analysis and write programs
and analyze the data.
Please install that.
It's really important, if
you don't already have that.
We use live scripts for
problems set submissions.
And Daniel made some
nice examples on Stellar.
And of course the guidelines
for Pset submissions
are also on Stellar.
OK, that's it.
Any questions about that?
No?
All right, good.
So let's go ahead
and get started then
with the first topic.
OK.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to build
a model of a neuron.
This model is very particular.
It uses electrical components
to describe the neuron.
Now that may not be surprising
since a neuron is basically
an electrical device.
It has components that
are sensitive to voltages,
that generate currents,
that control currents.
And so we're going to build our
model using electrical circuit
components.
And one of the nice
things about doing that
is that every electrical
circuit component,
like a resistor or
a capacitor, has
a very well-defined mathematical
relation between the current
and the voltage,
the current that
flows through that
device and the voltage
across the terminals
of that device.
So you can write down very
precisely, mathematically,
what each of those
components does.
So then you can then
take all those components
and construct a set of
equations or in general a set
of differential equations that
allows you to basically evolve
that circuit over time
and plot, let's say,
the voltage on the inside of
the cell as a function of time.
And you can see that that
model neuron can actually
very precisely replicate many
of the properties of neurons.
Now neurons are actually
really complicated.
And this is the real reason why
we need to write down a model.
So there are many
different kinds of neurons.
Each type of neuron
has a different pattern
of genes that are expressed.
So this is a cluster
diagram of neuron type based
on a transcriptional
profiling of the RNA
that I think it was about 13,000
neurons that were extracted
from a part of the brain.
You do a transcriptional
profiling.
It gives you a map of
all the different genes
are expressed in each neuron.
And then you can
cluster them and you
can see that this particular
part of the brain,
which is in the
hypothalamus, expresses all
of these different cell types.
Now what are those
different genes?
Many of those different
genes are actually
different ion channels.
And there are hundreds of
different kinds of ion channels
that control the flow of
current across the membrane
of the neuron.
So this is just a diagram
showing different potassium ion
channels, different
calcium ion channels.
You can see they have families
and different subtypes.
And all of those
different ion channels
have different
timescales on which
the current varies as a
function of voltage change.
They have different
voltage ranges
that they're sensitive to.
They have different
inactivation.
So many ion channels, when you
turn them on, they stay on.
But other ion
channels, they turn on
and then they slowly decay away.
The current slowly decays away.
And that's called inactivation.
And all these
different ion channels
have different combinations
of those properties.
And it's really
hard to predict when
you think about how
this neuron will
behave with a different
kind of ion channel here.
It's super hard to just look
at the properties of an ion
channel and just see how that's
going to work in a neuron
because you have all
these different parts that
are working together.
And so it's really important
to be able to write down
a mathematical model.
If you have a neuron that has a
different kind of ion channel,
you can actually predict how
the neuron's going to behave.
Now that's just the
ion channel components.
Neurons also have
complex morphologies.
This is a Purkinje
cell in the cerebellum.
They have these very densely
elaborated dendrites.
Other neurons have
very long dendrites
with just a few branches.
Other neurons have very
short stubby dendrites.
And each of those different
morphological patterns
also affects how a neuron
responds to its inputs,
because now a neuron
can have inputs
out here at the end of
the dendrite or up close
to the soma.
And all of those, the
spatial structure,
also affects how
a neuron responds.
And those produce very
different firing patterns.
So some neurons, if you
put in a constant current,
they just fire regularly up.
So it turns out we
can really understand
why all these
different things happen
if we build a model like this.
So let me just
point out a couple
of other interesting
things about this model.
Different parts of
this circuit actually
do cool different things.
So neurons have not
just one power supply.
They've got multiple
power supplies to power
up different parts
of the circuit that
do different things.
Neurons have
capacitances that allow
a neuron to accumulate over
time, act as an integrator.
If you combine a
capacitor with a resistor,
that circuit now
looks like a filter.
It smooths its past
inputs over time.
And these two components
here, this sodium current
and this potassium current,
make a spike generator
that generates an
action potential that
then talks to other neurons.
And you put that
whole thing together,
and that thing can act
like an oscillator.
It can act like a
coincidence detector.
It can do all kinds of
different cool things.
And all that stuff
is understandable
if you just write down a
simple model like this.
Any questions?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to just start
describing this network.
We're going to build it
up one piece at a time.
And we're going to start
with a capacitance.
But before we get
to the capacitor,
we need to do one more thing.
We need to do one
thing first, which
is figure out what the
wires are in the brain.
For an electrical circuit,
you need to have wires.
So what are the
wires in the brain?
What do wires do in a circuit?
They carry current.
So what are the
wires in a neuron?
AUDIENCE: Axons?
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
MICHALE FEE: Axons.
So axons carry information.
They carry a spike that
travels down the axon
and goes to other neurons.
But there is even a
simpler answer than that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Ion channels?
MICHALE FEE: Ion channels
are these resistors here.
But what is it that connects all
those components to each other?
AUDIENCE: Intracellular
and extracellular.
MICHALE FEE: Excellent.
It's the intracellular and
extracellular solution.
And so what we're
going to do today
is to understand how the
intracellular and extracellular
solution acts as a
wire in our neuron.
And it's not quite as
simple as a piece of metal.
It's a bit more complicated.
There are different
ways you can get
current flow in intracellular
and extracellular solution.
So we're going to
go through that
and we're going to analyze
that in some detail.
So in the brain, the wires
are the intracellular
and extracellular
salt solutions.
And you get current
flow that results
from the movement of ions
in that aqueous solution.
So the solution
consists of ions.
Like in the
extracellular, it's mostly
sodium ions and chloride ions
that are dissolved in water.
Water is a polar solvent.
That means that the negative
parts, the oxygen that's
slightly negatively charged.
Oxygen is attracted
toward positive ions.
And the intracellular
and extracellular space
are filled with salt
solution at a concentration
of about 100 millimolar.
And that corresponds
to having one
of these ions about
every 25 angstroms apart.
So at those
concentrations, there
are a lot of ions
floating around.
And those ions can move
under different conditions
to produce currents.
So currents flow in
the brain through two
primary different mechanisms.
Diffusion, which is
caused by variations
in the concentration.
And drifts of particles
in an electric field.
So when you put
an electric field,
so if you take a beaker
filled with salt solution,
you put two metal
electrodes in it,
you produce an
electric field that
causes these ions to drift in--
and that's another
source of current
that we're going
to look at today.
So here are our learning
objectives for today.
We're going to understand how
the timescales of diffusion
relate to the length scales.
That's a really
interesting story.
That's very important.
We're going to understand how
concentration gradients lead
to currents.
That's known as
Fick's First Law.
And we're going to
understand how charges drift
in an electric field in a
way that leads to current,
and the mathematical
relation that
describes voltage differences.
And this is called
Ohm's Law in the brain.
And we're going to learn about
the concept of resistivity.
So the first thing we
need to talk about,
if we're going to talk about
diffusion, is thermal energy.
So every particle
in the world is
being jostled by other particles
that are crashing into it.
And at thermal equilibrium,
every degree of freedom,
every way that a particle
can move, either forward
and backward, left and right,
up and down, or rotations,
this way or this way,
or whichever way,
I didn't show yet,
come to equilibrium
at a particular energy that's
proportional to temperature.
In other words, if
a particle is moving
in this direction
in equilibrium,
it will have a kinetic energy
in that direction that's
proportional to the temperature.
And that temperature
is in units of kelvin
relative to absolute zero.
And the proportionality constant
is the Boltzmann constant,
which has units of
joules per kelvin.
So when you multiply the
Boltzmann constant k times
temperature, what you find is
that every degree of freedom
will come to equilibrium
at 4 times 10
to the minus 21 joules,
which is an amount of energy,
at room temperature.
At zero temperature, you can
see that every degree of freedom
has zero energy.
And so nothing is moving.
Nothing's rotating, nothing's
moving any direction.
Everything's perfectly still.
So let's calculate
how fast particles
move at thermal equilibrium
in room temperature.
So you may remember from
your first physics class
that the kinetic
energy of a particle
is proportional to the velocity
squared, 1/2 mv squared.
So the average velocity
squared of a particle
at thermal equilibrium is just
1/2 times that much energy.
That makes sense?
Now we [AUDIO OUT] how
fast a particle is moving--
for example, a sodium ion.
So you can see that the average
velocity squared is just
kT over m.
We just divide both sides by m.
So the average velocity
squared is kT over m.
The mass of a
sodium ion is this.
So the average
velocity squared is
10 to the 5 meter squared
per second squared.
Just take the square
root that, and you
get the average velocity
is 320 meters per second.
So that means that the
air molecules, which
have a similar
mass to sodium ion,
are whizzing around at
300 meters per second.
So that would cross this room
in a few hundredths of a second.
But of course, that's
not what happens.
Particles don't just go whizzing
along at 300 meters per second.
What happens to them?
AUDIENCE: Bump into each other.
MICHALE FEE: Into each other.
They're all crashing into
each other constantly.
So in solution, a particle
collides with a water molecule
every about 10 to the
13 times per second.
10 to the minus 13 seconds
between collisions.
So that means the particle is
moving a little bit crashing,
moving in a different
direction, crashing,
direction and crashing.
So if you follow one particle,
it's just jumping around,
it's diffusing.
So what does that look like?
Daniel made a little
video that shows to scale.
This is position in micron.
And time is in real-time.
So this video shows in real-time
what the motion of a particle
might look like.
In each point, it's moving,
colliding, and moving off
in some random direction.
You can actually see this.
If you look at a
very small particle--
who was it, Daniel, who did that
experiment looking at pollen?
It's Brownian, at Brown.
AUDIENCE: Yup.
MICHALE FEE: What
was his first name?
Brown.
Brownian motion.
Have you heard of
Brownian motion?
So somebody named
Brown was looking
at pollen particles in water and
noticing that they jump around,
just like this.
And he hypothesized that they
were being jostled around
by the water.
Any questions?
So what can we say about this?
There's something really
interesting about diffusion
that's very
non-intuitive at first.
Diffusion has some really
strange aspect to it.
That a distance that
a particle can diffuse
depends very much on
the time that you allow.
And it's not just
a simple relation.
So let's just look at this.
So let's ask how
much time does it
take for an ion to
diffuse a short distance,
like across the
soma of a neuron.
So an ion can diffuse
across the soma of a neuron
in about a 20th of a second.
How about down it at dendrites.
So let's start our
ion in the cell body.
And ask, how long
does it take an iron
to reach the end of a dendrite
that can be about a millimeter
away.
Can take about 10
minutes on average.
That's how long it
will take an iron
to get that far away
from its starting point.
So you can see, 20th
of a second here.
And here it's like 500 seconds.
About 10 minutes.
How long does it take an ion,
starting at the cell body,
to diffuse all the way down--
so you know there are
neurons in your body that
start in your spinal cord and go
all the way down to your feet.
So motor neurons in your spinal
cord can have very long axons.
So how long does it take
an ion to get from the soma
all the way down to the end
of an axon, a long axon?
Somebody just take a guess.
It's 20th of a second
here, 10 minutes here.
Anybody want to guess?
An hour, yup.
10 years.
OK.
Why is that?
That's crazy, right?
How is that possible?
And that's an ion.
So a cell body is making
proteins and all kinds of stuff
that have to get down
to build synapses
at the other end of that axon.
And proteins diffuse a heck
of a lot slower than ions do.
So basically a cell body
could make stuff for the axon,
and it would never get there
in your entire lifetime.
And that's why cells have to
actually make little trains.
They literally
make little trains.
They package up stuff
and put it on the train
and it just marches down the
axon until it gets to the end.
And this is the reason why.
So what we're going to do is
I'm going to just walk you
through a very simple
derivation of why this is true
and how to think about this.
So here's what
we're going to do.
So normally things diffuse
in three dimensions, right?
But it's just much harder
to analyze things in three
dimensions..
So you can get basically
the right answer
just by analyzing how things
diffuse in one dimension.
So Daniel made this
little video to show you
what this looks like.
This is I think 100 particles
all lined up near zero.
And we're going to
turn on the video.
We're going to let them all
start diffusing at one moment.
So you can just watch
what happens to all
these different particles.
So you can see that
some particles end up
over here on the left.
Other particles end up
over here on the right.
You can see that the
distribution of particles
spreads out.
And so we're going to figure out
why that is, why that happens.
So the first thing I
just want to tell you
is that the distribution
of particles,
if they all start at
zero, and they diffuse
in 1D away from zero, the
distribution that you get
is Gaussian.
And the basic reason is that,
let's start at the center,
and on every time step they
have a probability of 1/2
of going to the right and
1/2 of going to the left.
And so basically there
are many more combinations
of ways a particle can do
some lefts and do some rights
and end up back
where it started.
It's very unlikely
that the particle
will do a whole bunch of
going right all in a row.
And so that's why the
density and the distribution
is very low down here.
And so you end up
with something that's
just a Gaussian distribution.
So let's analyze this
in a little more detail.
So we're going to just make a
very simple model of particles
stepping to the
right or to the left.
We're going to consider
a particle that
is moving left or right at a
fixed velocity vx for some time
tau before a collision.
And we're going to imagine
that each time the particle
collides it resets its velocity
randomly, either to the left
or to the right.
So on every time step,
half the particles
will step right by
a distance delta,
which is the velocity
times the time tau.
And the other half
of the particles
will step left by
that same distance.
So they're going either to
the left or to the right
by a distance delta.
So if we start with n
particles and all of them
start at position
0 at time 0, then
we can write down the position
of every particle at time step
n, the i-th particle
at time step n.
And we're going to assume that
each particle is independent,
each doing their own
thing, ignoring each other.
So now you can see
that you can write down
the position of the particle
at time step n is just
at the previous time
step, plus or minus
this little delta.
Any questions about that?
So please, if you ever just
haven't followed one step
that I do, just let me know.
I'm happy to explain it again.
I often am watching somebody
explaining something really
simple, and my brain is
just in some funny state
and I just don't get it.
So it's totally fine if you want
me to explain something again.
You don't have to be
embarrassed because happens
to me all the time.
So now what we can do
is use this expression,
compute how that distribution
evolves over time,
how that distribution of
particles, this i-th particle
over time, time step n.
All right, so let's calculate
what the average position
of the ensemble is.
So these brackets mean average.
So the bracket with an
i, that I'm averaging
this quantity over i particles.
And so it's just
the sum of positions
for every particle, divided
by the number of particles.
That's the average position.
So again, the position of the
i-th particle at time step n
is just the position of that
particle at the previous time
step, plus or minus delta.
We just plug that into
there, into there.
And now we calculate the sum.
But we have two terms.
We have this term and that term.
Let's break them up
into two separate sums.
So this is equal to the sum
over the previous positions,
plus the sum over how
much the change was
from one time step to the next.
Does that makes sense?
But what is this sum?
We're summing over
all the particles,
how much they changed from
the previous time step
to this time step.
Well, half of them moved to
the right and half of them
the left.
So that sum is just zero.
So you can see that
the average position
of the particles
at this time step
is just equal to the average
position of the particles
at the previous time step.
And what that means is that
the center of the distribution
hasn't changed.
If you start all the particles
at zero, they diffuse around.
The average position
is still zero.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
bracket [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
So this here is just this.
So this bracket means I'm
averaging over this quantity i.
So you can see that's
what I'm doing here.
I'm summing over i and dividing
by the number of particles.
AUDIENCE: And what is i?
MICHALE FEE: I is
the particle number.
So if we have 10 particles,
i goes from 1 to 10.
Thank you.
So that's a little boring.
But we used a trick
here that we're
going to use now to
actually calculate
the interesting thing, which
is on average how far do
the particles get from
where they started.
So what we're going to do is not
calculate the average position
of all the particles.
We're going to calculate
the average absolute value
from where they started.
Does that makes sense?
We're going to ask, on average,
how far did they get from where
they started, which was zero.
So absolute values,
nobody likes.
They're hard to deal with.
But this is exactly the same
as calculating the square root
of the average square.
It's the same as
calculating the variance.
Does that makes sense?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to calculate the
variance of that distribution.
And the square root
of that variance
is just the standard deviation,
which is just how wide it is,
which is just how far on
average the particles got
from where they started.
Does that makes sense?
So let's push on.
We're going to calculate
the average square distance.
Now we're just going to take
the square of that at the end.
So the average of the
position squared, we're
going to plug this into here.
So we're going to square it.
So the position of
the particle squared
is just this quantity squared.
Let's factor it out.
So we have this term
squared plus twice
that times that here,
plus that term squared.
And we're going to
now plug that average.
So the average position
squared is just the average.
The average position
squared at this time step n
is the average position
squared at the previous time
step plus some other stuff.
And let's take a look at
what that other stuff is.
What is this?
This is plus or
minus 2 times delta,
which is the step it takes,
the size of the step times x.
So what is that average?
Half of these are positive and
half of these are negative.
So the average is zero.
And quantity is the
average of delta squared.
Well, delta squared is
always positive, right?
So what does this say?
What this says is that the
variance at this time step
is just the variance
at a previous time step
is a constant.
So let's analyze that.
What this says is that
at each time step,
the variance grows
by some constant.
Delta is a distance.
Delta squared is just the units
of variance of a distribution
that's a function of distance.
So if the variance
at time step 0 is 0,
that means they're all
lined up at the origin.
One time step later, the
variance will be delta squared.
The next time step, it
will be two delta squared.
The next time step,
dot, dot, dot.
Up at some time step n, it
will be n times delta squared.
So you see what's happening?
The variance of
this distribution
is growing linearly.
We can change from time
steps to continuous time.
So the step number
is just time divided
by tau, which is
some interval in time
like the interval
between collisions.
And so you can see that
the variance is just
growing linearly in time where
the variance is just 2 times d
times T, where d is what we
call the diffusion coefficient.
It's just length
squared divided by time.
Why is that?
Because as time grows, the
variance grows linearly.
So if we want to take
time, multiply it
by something that
gives us variance,
it has to be variance
per unit time.
And variance, for
something that's
a distribution of position,
has to have position squared.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But do we like
[INAUDIBLE],, like that?
MICHALE FEE: It's built
into the definition
of the diffusion constant, OK?
Any questions about that?
And now here here's the answer.
So the variance is
growing linearly in time.
What that means is that
the standard deviation,
the average distance
from the starting point,
is growing as the
square root of time.
And that's key.
That I want you to remember.
The distance that
a particle diffuses
from its starting
point on average grows
is the square root of time.
So for a small molecule,
a typical small molecule,
the diffusion constant is 10 to
the minus 5 centimeters squared
per second.
And so now we can just plug
in some distances in times
and see how long it
takes this particle
to diffuse some distance.
So let's do that.
Let's plug in a
length of 10 microns.
That was our soma,
our cell body.
It's 10 to the
minus 3 centimeters.
Time is that squared,
length squared.
So it's 10 to the minus 6
centimeters squared divided
by the diffusion constant.
2 times the diffusion constant,
2 times 10 to the minus 5
centimeters squared per second.
You can see centimeter
squareds cancel.
That leaves us time.
50 milliseconds.
Now let's put in one millimeter.
That was the length
of our dendrite.
So that's 10 to the
minus 1 centimeter.
So we plug that into
our equation for time.
Time is just L squared--
I forgot to actually
write that down.
Here's the equation
that I'm solving.
So what this equation at
the bottom here is saying
is some distance is equal
to the square root of 2dT.
And I'm just saying L
squared is equal to 2 dT.
And I'm solving for
T, L squared over 2d.
That's the equation I'm solving.
I'm giving you a length and I'm
calculating how long it takes.
So if you put in 10
to the minus 1 here,
you get 10 to the minus
2 divided by 2 times 10
to the minus 500 seconds,
which is about 10 minutes.
And now if you ask how long
does it take to go a meter,
that's 10 to the 2 centimeters.
That's 10 to the 4 divided
by 10 to the minus 5.
Somebody over here
figured it out right away.
About 5 times 10
to the 8 seconds,
which is about 10 years.
A year is pi times 10 to
the 7 seconds, by the way.
Plus or minus a few percent.
Any questions about that?
Cool, right?
So neurons and cells
and biology has
to go to extraordinary lengths
to overcome this craziness
of diffusion, which explains
a lot of the structure you
see in cells.
So you can see that
diffusion causes
the movement of ions
from places where
they're concentrated to places
where there aren't so many
ions.
So let's take a little
bit slightly more
detail look at that idea.
So what I'm going to
tell you about now
is called Fick's First Law.
And the idea is that
diffusion produces
a net flow of particles from
regions of high concentration
to regions of lower
concentration.
And the flux of
particles is proportional
to the concentration gradient.
Now this is just
really obvious, right?
If you have a box, and on the
left side of the box you have n
particles.
Then on the right
side of the box then
you're going to have particles
diffusing from here to there.
And you're going
to have particles
diffusing from there to there.
But because there are
more of them over here,
they're just going to be
more particles going this way
than there are that way.
Does that makes sense?
Let's say each
particle here might
have a 50% chance of
diffusing here or staying here
or diffusing somewhere else.
Particles here also
equally have probability
of going either way.
But just because there
are more of them here,
there's going to be more
particles going that way.
You can just
calculate the number
of particles going this way
minus the number of particles
going that way.
And that gives
you the net number
of particles going to the right.
But what does that look like?
You have the number here minus
the number some distance away.
And what if you were to
divide that by the distance?
What would that look like?
Good.
It looks like a derivative.
So if you calculate
the flux, it's
minus the diffusion
constant times
1 over delta, the separation
between these boxes.
It's the concentration here
minus the concentration there.
And that is just a derivative.
And that's Fick's First Law.
I have a few slides at the
end of the lecture that
do this derivation
more completely.
So please take a look at
that if you have time.
So now this is really
an important concept.
This Fick's First Law, the fact
that concentration gradients
produce a flow of
ions, of particles,
is so fundamental
to how neurons work.
And here we're
going to be building
that up over the course of
the next couple lectures.
So imagine that you
have a cell that
has a lot of potassium
ions inside and very
few potassium ions outside.
Now you can see
that you're going
to have potassium ions
diffusing from here.
Sorry, and I forgot
to say, let's
say that your cell
has a hole in it.
So you're going to have
potassium ions diffusing
from inside to outside
through the hole.
You also have some
potassium ions out here.
And some of those
might diffuse in.
But there are just so
many more potassium ions
inside than outside
concentration-wise
that the probability of one
going out through the hole
is just much higher than the
probability of a potassium ion
going back into the cell.
So here I'm just zooming
in on that channel,
on that pore through
the membrane.
Lots of potassium ions here.
On average, there's going to
be a net flow of potassium
out through that hole.
And we can plot the
concentration gradient
through the hole.
And you can see it's
high here, it decreases,
and it's low outside.
And so there's a net flow that's
proportional to the steepness
of concentration profile.
So that's true,
you get a net flow,
even if each particle is
diffusing independently.
They don't know anything
about each other.
And yet that concentration
gradient produces a current.
All concentration
gradients go away.
Why is that?
Because calcium ions will flow
from the inside of the cell
to the outside of the cell until
they're the same concentration.
And then you'll
have just as many
flowing back inside as
you have flowing outside.
Why?
So eventually that would
happen to all of our cells.
Why doesn't that happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
because they're alive.
MICHALE FEE: Well, that's
exactly the right answer,
but there are a few
intermediate steps.
If you were to not
be alive anymore,
the potassium ions
would just diffuse out.
And that would be the end.
But what happens is
there are other proteins
in the membrane that take
those potassium ions from here
and pump them back inside and
maintain the concentration
gradient.
But that costs energy.
Those proteins use ATP.
And that ATP comes from eating.
But eventually all
concentration gradients go away.
So that is how we
get current flow
from concentration gradients.
Now the next topic has to do
with the diffusion of ions
in the presence of
voltage differences,
voltage gradients.
The bottom line here
that I want you to know,
that I want you to understand,
is that current flow in neurons
obeys Ohm's Law.
Now what does that mean?
Let's imagine that
we have a resistor.
Let's say across a membrane
or in the intracellular
or extracellular
space of a neuron.
The current flow through
that resistive medium
is proportional to the
voltage difference.
So that's Ohm's Law.
The current is proportional
to the voltage difference
across the two terminals, the
two sides of the resistor.
And the proportionality constant
is 1 over the resistance.
So here current has
units of amperes.
The voltage difference
is units of volts.
And the resistance
has units of ohms.
Any questions about that?
So let's go through--
let's develop this
idea a little bit more
and understand why it is that
a voltage difference produces
a current that's
proportional to voltage.
So let's go back to
our little [AUDIO OUT]
filled with salt solution.
There are ions in here
dissolved in the water.
We have two metal plates.
We've put a battery between
the two metal plates that
holds those two plates at
some fixed voltage difference
delta v. And we're going
to ask what happens.
So let's zoom in here.
There is one plate
that's at one potential.
There's another plate
at another potential.
There's some voltage
difference between those
that's delta v. The two plates
are separated by a distance L.
And that voltage difference
produces an electric field
that points from the
high voltage region
to the low voltage region.
So an electric field produces
a force on a charge--
we have lots of
charges in here--
that's proportional to the
charge and the electric field.
So what is that
force going to do?
That force is just going
to drag that particle
through the liquid,
through the water.
So why is it?
So if this were a vacuum in
here and we put a charge there
and metal plates and we
put a battery across,
what would that particle do?
It would move.
But what would this force
do to that particle?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
So what would the velocity do?
AUDIENCE: Increase.
MICHALE FEE: It would
just increase linearly.
So the particle
would start moving.
And it would start moving
slowly and it'd go--
poof-- crash into the plate.
But that's not
what happens here.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Because
there's stuff in the way.
And so it accelerates, and it
gets hit by a water molecule.
And it gets pushed
off in some direction.
And then it accelerates in
this direction, gets hit again.
But it's constantly being
accelerated in one direction
before it collides.
And so here's what happens.
So it's diffusing around.
But on each step, it has a
little bit of acceleration
in this direction,
in the direction
of the electric field.
And so you can show using
the same kind of analysis
that we used in calculating
the distribution, the change
in mean and variance,
you can show
that mean of a
distribution of particles
that starts at zero shifts--
of positive particles
shifts in the electric field
linearly in time.
And you can just think about
that as the electric field
reaches in, grabs that
charged particle, and pulls it
in this direction
against viscous drag.
So now a force produces
a constant velocity, not
acceleration.
And that velocity is
called the drift velocity.
So the force is proportional
to drift velocity.
What is that little f there?
Anybody know what that is?
AUDIENCE: Frictional
coefficient.
MICHALE FEE: It's
the coefficient
of friction of that particle.
And Einstein cleverly
noticed that the coefficient
of friction of a particle
being dragged through a liquid
is related to what?
Any guess?
Diffusion coefficient
of that particle.
Is that cool?
That just gives me chills.
The frictional
coefficient is just
kT over the diffusion constant.
So if you actually just go
through that same analysis
of calculating the mean of the
distribution, what you find
is that v moves
linearly in time.
But it's also very intuitive.
If you're in a swimming pool,
you put your hand in the water,
and you push your hand
with a constant force.
What happens?
Well, let me flip it around.
You move your hand through the
water at a constant velocity.
What is the force feel like?
The force is constant, right?
So flip it the other way around.
If the force is
constant, then you're
going to get a
constant velocity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So side
question, but you can also
look at that like a
terminal velocity problem?
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
It's exactly the same thing.
So the drift velocity is
proportional to the force
by proportionality constant,
1 over the coefficient
of friction, which
is now d over kT.
And what is this
force proportional to?
Anybody remember?
The force was proportional
to the electric field.
And so let's
calculate the current.
So I'm going to argue
that the current is
proportional to the drift
velocity times the area.
Now why is that?
So if I have an
electric field, it
makes these particles, all
the particles in this area
here drift at a constant
velocity in this direction.
So there is a certain
amount of current
that's flowing in
this area right here.
Does that makes sense?
Now if my electrodes are big
and I also have electric field
up here, then that
electric field
is causing current
to flow up here too.
And if there's
electric field up here,
then there will be current
flowing up here too.
And so you can see that the
amount of current that's
flowing between the electrodes
is proportional to the drift
velocity and the cross-sectional
area between the two
electrodes.
Yes?
So that's really important.
Now we figured out
that the drift velocity
is proportional to
the electric field.
So the current is proportional
to the electric field
times the area.
And the electric field is
just the voltage difference
divided by the spacing
between the electrodes.
And so the current is
proportional to voltage
times area divided by length.
So we have a proportionality.
Current is
proportional to voltage
times area divided by length.
And now let's plug in what that
proportionality constant is.
This is now like
Ohm's Law, right?
We're saying the current
is proportional to voltage
difference.
The thing that the
proportionality constant
here is something
called resistivity.
Otherwise known as conductivity.
But we're going to
use resistivity.
So this is just Ohm's Law.
It says current is proportional
to voltage difference.
Let's rewrite that a
little bit so that it
looks more like Ohm's Law.
Current is proportional
to voltage difference.
And that thing, that
thingy right there,
should have units of what?
1 over ohms.
Right?
So that is 1 over resistance.
Let's just write down
what the resistance is.
Resistance is just resistivity
times length divided by area.
So let's just stop
and take a breath
and think about why
this makes sense.
Resistance is how
much resistance there
is to flow at a
given voltage, right?
So what happens if we
make ours really small?
What happens to the resistance?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
really big.
MICHALE FEE: The
resistance gets big.
The amount of current gets
small because there's less area
that the electric field is in.
And so the current goes down.
That means the
resistance is big.
If we make our
plates really big,
the resistance gets smaller.
What happens if we pull
our plates further apart?
What happens to the resistance?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
further apart.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
If the plates are further
apart, L is bigger,
and resistance is bigger.
But conceptually,
what's going on?
Physically, what's going?
The plates are further
apart, so what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Right.
The voltage difference
is the same,
but the distance is bigger.
And so the electric field,
which is voltage per distance,
is smaller.
And that smaller electric field
produces a drift velocity.
And that's why the
resistance goes up.
Cool, right?
OK.
Now, let's talk for a
minute about resistivity.
So resistivity in the brain
is really, really lousy.
The wires of the
brain are just awful.
So if you look at the
resistivity for copper, which
is which is the wire
that's used in electronics,
the resistivity is 1.6
microohms times centimeters.
What that means is if I took a
block of copper, a centimeter
on a side, and I put
electrodes on the side of it,
and I measured the resistance,
it would be 1.6 microohms.
That means I could run an amp,
that thing with 1.6 microvolts.
Now the resistivity of the
brain is 60 ohms centimeters.
That means a centimeter of
block of saline solution,
intracellular or
extracellular solution,
has a resistance of 60 ohms
instead of 1.6 microohms.
It's more than a
million times worse.
And what that means is that
when you try to send current
through brain, you try
to send some current,
the voltage just drops.
You need huge voltage drops
to produce tiny currents.
That's why the brain
has invented things--
axons-- because the
wires are so bad that you
can't send a signal from
one part of the brain
to another part of the
brain through the wire.
You have to invent this special
gimmick called an action
potential to send a signal
more than a few microns away.
It's pretty cool, right?
That's why it's so interesting
to understand the basic physics
of something, the basic
mechanisms by which something
works because most
of what you see
is a hack to compensate
for weird physics, right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: This
high resistivity--
you're asking what causes
that high resistivity.
It basically has to do with
things like the mean-free path
of the particle.
So in a metal, particles
can go further effectively
before they collide.
So the resistivity is lower.
AUDIENCE: Is that
slope [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: It's a little
bit different inside the cell
because there's more
gunk inside of a cell
than there is outside of a cell.
And so the resistivity
is a little bit worse.
It's 2,000 ohms centimeters,
or 1,000 or 2,000
inside the cell and
more like 60 outside.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes once
you're outside the cell,
it's basically the
same everywhere.
OK?
So that's it.
So here's what we
learned about today.
We understood the relation
between the timescale
of diffusion and length scales.
And we learned that the distance
that a particle can diffuse
grows only as the
square root of time.
We understood how concentration
gradients lead to currents.
And we talked about
Fick's First Law
that says that concentration
differences lead
to particle flux.
The flux is proportional to
the gradient or the derivative
of the concentration.
And we also talked about how
the drift of charged particles
in an electric field
leads to currents,
and how the voltage current
relation obeys Ohm's Law.
And we also talked about
the concept of resistivity
and how the resistivity in
the brain is really high
and makes the wires in
the brain really bad.
So that's all I have.
I will take any questions.
Yes, Daniel?
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to introduce David.
MICHALE FEE: OK.
Our other TA is here.
Any questions?
Great.
So we will see you--
when is the first [AUDIO OUT]?
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Tomorrow.
MICHALE FEE: Tomorrow.
So I will see you Thursday.